[Music]
foreign
so we've been talking a lot about
differential equations x dot equals f of
x and I've been saying a lot you know
this is a linear differential equation
or a linear system of differential
equations and so I wanted to slow down
and really give like a kind of
quick overview of what it even means to
be linear in the first place so what
is linear linearity is a huge huge
Concept in math it's a huge concept like
you have linear algebra matrices and
vectors you have linear differential
equations and it occurred to me maybe
some of you kind of don't know or don't
remember exactly definitionally what it
means to be linear and so I'm going to
just give a really quick overview of
what that means especially in the
context of differential equations
we're talking about a for example a
linear ode a linear ordinary
differential equation would be a
differential equation like x dot equals
some Matrix a times x where let's say x
is a vector of States a is a matrix and
x dot is the first derivative of x with
respect to time
so um any differential equation system
that can be written as x dot equals a
matrix a times x
is in fact linear that is a linear
system of ordinary differential
equations
and maybe what I'll do is I'll start off
I'll revisit this in a minute but I'm
going to start off by by giving you a
really simple example of
um
something like X double dot plus 3 x dot
plus 2X equals zero we've looked at this
differential equation before I also
claim that this is a linear differential
equation
because essentially it's just you know
x's and derivatives of x's and
multiplication by numbers there's no X
squareds or signs of x's or cosines of
x's there's no non-linear functions of X
or X as derivatives in here and so we
know
um
we know that both
um
let's call it X1 of T equals e to the
minus t
and X2 of T equals e to the minus 2 of T
both of these are solutions
okay you could uh refresh yourself on
this and remind yourself by for example
Computing the characteristic polynomial
of this Lambda squared plus 3 Lambda
plus two equals zero and the roots are
Lambda equals negative one and negative
two and so this gives the two
fundamental Solutions of this
differential equation and because this
is linear this is linear
because this differential equation is
linear any combination of these two
solutions is also a solution of this
differential equation so that's a huge
huge benefit of linearity in our
differential equations is that if my
differential equation is linear and I
have two solutions then I can add up
those Solutions and there's still a
solution to this differential equation
so I actually want to just just confirm
that is true so let's say you know X of
T equals any constant Alpha e to the
minus t plus any other constant beta e
to the minus 2T is also
a solution
specifically because this is a linear
differential equation so superposition
holds this is called linear
superposition this is called linear
superposition
it is super uh linear superposition I'll
give you some other examples of
superposition in a minute like you can
add up different sine waves to build
some function that's what the Fourier
transform does again relying on linear
superposition but I'm just going to
confirm that any if these two are
solutions then any linear combination is
also a solution this is pretty easy to
show so we'll just compute you know x
dot equals minus Alpha e to the minus t
minus 2 Beta e to the minus 2T X double
dot equals minus minuses plus Alpha e to
the minus t minus minus is plus 4 beta e
to the minus 2T
and so now I can take these expressions
and plug them into my differential
equation here it's pretty simple so I'm
just going to do that maybe I'll do that
in pink
and I'm going to add up you know X
double dot plus 3x dot plus 2 x and I'm
going to get and I'm going to group all
of my Alpha terms and all of my Beta
terms so all of my Alpha terms I'm going
to get you know Alpha e to the minus t
plus
three times you know negative Alpha e to
the minus t
Plus
2 Alpha e to the minus t that's all of
my Alpha terms
and now I'm going to group all of my
Beta terms in this expression so X
double dot is plus 4 beta e to the minus
2T uh
plus 3 times negative 2 is minus six
beta e to the minus 2T plus two x is
plus 2 Beta
e to the minus 2T and you can kind of
already see that I have you know Alpha
minus 3 Alpha plus 2 Alpha that's zero
Alphas so this equals zero
and if I have four betas minus six betas
plus two betas again that's four minus
six plus two is zero betas so both of
these add up to zero and this satisfies
our differential equation so this is
really really simple and kind of I just
hope that that this convinces you that
if I have two solutions of a linear
differential equation and I add those up
in any combination Alpha of the first
solution plus beta of the second
solution when I plug that into my
differential equation because basically
additivity adding these functions this
is kind of linear Point wise in time uh
when I plug when I compute its
derivatives and plug it into this
differential equation
I basically have all of the terms from
the first Alpha part of the equation and
of course that solved the equation so
that equaled zero and I also have all of
the terms from the second solution all
of those beta terms and of course those
add up to zero because that was a
solution and so uh adding them together
is also a solution
so for a differential equation
if I have multiple Solutions I can add
them up and it's still a solution that's
a huge huge benefit and a huge property
of linear differential equations which
allows us to solve these these systems
okay
um and in fact that's what's allowing us
to solve these Matrix systems of
equations so for example you know we are
oftentimes changing coordinates into
eigenvector or eigenvalue coordinates so
I do something like I say
um you know Z what did I say I said x
equals T times Z
so I say
um you know introduce a new coordinate
system x equals t z so that Z dot equals
a diagonal matrix times Z
and what this means is that these are
Matrix systems of equations of course
in if I have this Matrix system of
equations and I diagonalize it so t or
the eigenvectors of my a matrix and I
put this into a diagonal form in Z
coordinates now each of those Z's can be
decoupled and I get a solution for the
Z1 component and the Z2 component and
the Z3 and Z4 and so on and so forth and
they're each decoupled little you know
Solutions but then when I write down my
full solution X at times t
equals
um
T times e to the Matrix DT times T
inverse times x naught essentially what
I'm doing is I'm taking all of those
little independent Solutions in Z
coordinates and I'm taking a linear
combination of them to add up this
solution X of T so again you can only do
that this kind of eigen decomposition
based on linear algebra for these linear
systems this only works of linear
superposition holds
um good and so of course you can do the
same thing here if I have two solutions
uh of this system I can add those up and
I still get a solution that's that's
also true for these these Matrix systems
of equations because essentially a
matrix multiplication is a linear
operation
so maybe that's something to show you
now is just give you examples of what
are linear operations so what
operations
are linear
before I do this maybe I'll give you a
counter example so I've been talking
about what is linear I'll give you an
example of something that's not linear
okay so not linear
would be something like the function f
of x equals x squared okay so if I take
you know uh f of x and that equals x
squared and I take F of Y and that
equals y squared if this was linear then
f of x plus y would equal f of x plus F
of Y and that's not the case so let's
confirm so f of x
plus y
is equal to
X Plus y squared which equals x squared
plus y squared plus 2xy and this does
not equal
f of x plus F of Y so this is a good
example of a function that is not linear
in fact any any function of X like sine
of x cosine of x x squared log of x root
x x cubed anything that's not just X or
5x or something you know simple and X is
going to be non-linear
this function is non-linear specifically
because f of x plus Y is not the sum of
f of x plus F of Y there's this extra
term here because of the non-linearity
and so this is a good example of
something that's not linear a non-linear
function and
a differential equation would be really
nasty
um
so so linear means F of
X Plus y equals f of x plus F of Y any
linear function f satisfies this and
even more generally it satisfies F of
any number Alpha X Plus any number beta
y
equals Alpha f of x
plus beta F of Y for any
number
numbers uh Alpha comma beta okay so this
is kind of the working definition of
what it means for a function to be
linear a function is linear if this is
true for any Alpha and any beta
uh and so some really good examples of
this are a derivative
um the the function you know f of x
equals
um
DX DT that's a linear function we can
verify this because if we take
um
DDT
of any function Alpha X Plus beta y
let's say x is a function of T and Y is
a function of t
We Know by the you know just properties
of the derivative that this equals this
constant can pop out of that derivative
this equals Alpha
DX DT
plus beta d y d t and so this equals
Alpha
f of x plus beta F of Y where f means
take the derivative with respect to time
okay so this is super useful the
derivative of x x dot is a linear
operator on X it's linear X double dot
is linear x triple dot X quadruple dot
any derivative of x with respect to time
if that's my function that's a linear
operator and so you can verify that and
verify that if I did this for if f of x
was D squared x DT that that would also
be linear it's pretty pretty trivial
um so that's good so derivatives are
linear let's say that
um you know derivatives
are linear
matrix multiplication is linear I'm
going to erase my nonlinear function
here so matrix multiplication is is also
linear if I have uh you know my function
of x equals just a matrix a times x
that's also a linear function
and I'll just write that out once I
finish erasing this usually I speed this
up and now you can see that this is
actually tedious to erase this board
uh good
so
matrix multiplication
so if I have f of x
and let's say this is a vector X if that
equals some Matrix a
times x I claim that this is also a
linear function or a linear operator on
X and so if I took my a matrix times you
know some constant Alpha
uh X I can call this X1 or Y it doesn't
matter let's call it X1 plus some beta
constant times a vector X2 we know again
by matrix multiplication
um if I take you can actually if you
really wanted to you could actually
build your Matrix a
and you could literally build a vector
that is you know alpha x 1 1 plus beta x
2 1 Alpha x 1 2 the second component of
X Plus beta x 2 2 and so on and so forth
and you could actually go through and do
the multiplication of this vector and
you'll see that this will split
into a constant Alpha
times a X1
plus a constant beta times a
X2 that might actually be a really good
exercise for you is to like pause here
and actually take this write this Vector
out multiply it by an arbitrary a matrix
a11 a12 a13 a21 a22 a23 an arbitrary a
matrix and convince yourself that it
actually splits this way so that yes in
fact it is linear this is a linear
operator and that's why if I have two
solutions any linear combination of
those Solutions is also a solution
so really really really important I'm
going to erase this because it's right
where I want to be standing uh really
really important to note is that
functions so so this is just a generic
definition of what it means to be a
linear function it means that this
superposition holds if I have f of x
plus F you know plus y it equals f of x
plus F of Y that is true for any linear
function
and what's really really useful is
linear ordinary differential equations
which means differential equations that
only have you know derivatives and
linear operators of x
linear superposition holds so if I have
multiple Solutions then I can add those
Solutions up in any proportion I want
and this will still be a solution of my
differential equation and so again you
know derivatives any amount of
derivatives I take of X that's a linear
operator matrix multiplication that's a
linear operator so this is in fact a
linear differential equation
if I had weird exotic things like if I
had some fractional derivative there are
derivative fractional derivatives you
can take the the one-half derivative of
x with respect to T to the one-half that
does exist that's called a fractional
derivative that might mess up my
linearity okay if I took you know a
times x cubed that would mess up my
linearity and linear superposition
generically would not hold so we kind of
are massively relying on linear
superposition to take these systems and
break them down into smaller sub
problems like in this system I broke it
down into these two fundamental
Solutions which I can then add up in
this system I break it down into its
kind of eigenvalue its diagonal
eigenvalue system which has a bunch of
different decoupled solutions and then I
recombine those that all uses linear
superposition based on the fact that
these differential equations themselves
are linear built out of linear operators
like the derivative and matrix
multiplication
okay so when I say this system is linear
I hope you now know what I mean and it's
a big deal linearity pretty much most of
the math we can actually solve in closed
form with generic solution techniques
are for linear systems linear algebra is
a subset of this massive field of
abstract algebra and linear algebra are
some of the only problems we can solve
in closed form using matrices and
vectors similarly linear differential
equations are a tiny tiny subset of all
of differential equations but these are
the only ones that we have kind of a
one-size-fits-all solution technique you
know and namely Computing the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of this a
matrix and then you know taking this
special combination of those solutions
to get the full solution of x so neat
stuff I just wanted to slow down and
really make sure you have a gut feeling
of what it means to be linear
derivatives or linear operators matrix
multiplication as linear what is linear
superposition mean
um and linear superposition is going to
come up all over the place when we talk
about partial differential equations
which we're going to solve with Fourier
transforms and Laplace transforms we're
also going to use linear superposition
in fact the Fourier transform is another
linear operator the singular value
decomposition is a linear operator the
Laplace transform is a linear operator
you know and there's a reason that most
of our engineering math focuses on these
linear operators because those are
almost the only ones that we can uh
generically write down in closed form
and because superposition holds for for
those linear operators so we like to
work with them
okay that's kind of everything I wanted
to show you and again we're really
focusing on these differential equations
and linear Odes are easier to solve
because linear superposition holds all
right thank you
[Music]